SEE YOU TOMORROW.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
ANY DAY JOE BIDEN WILL ANNOUNCE
HIS PICK FOR THE ACTUAL
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE, THE PERSON
WHO WILL RUN THE GOVERNMENT IF
BIDEN WINS IN NOVEMBER.
WE’VE BEEN TELLING YOU ABOUT
THIS PROCESS FOR WEEKS.
WE HAVE TAKEN A CLOSER LOOK AT
THREE POTENTIAL CANDIDATES, ALL
ARE SAID TO BE ON JOE BIDEN
SHORT-LIST.
STACEY ABRAMS, KAREN BASS,
KAMALA HARRIS.
IN A NORMAL YEAR, NO MAINSTREAM
CANDIDATE WOULD CONSIDER ANY OF
THESE PEOPLE.
ALL OF THEM WOULD BE
DISQUALIFIED WITHOUT DEBATE.
KAREN BASS IS A LUNATIC
FIDEL CASTRO ACOLYTE WHO PRAISED
SCIENTOLOGY AND ONCE BELONGED TO
AN ARMED REVOLUTIONARY GROUP.
SHE IS OUT.
STACEY ABRAMS IS SO DELUSIONAL,
SHE THINKS SHE’S THE GOVERNOR OF
GEORGE AND BY THE WAY SHE’S
ESSENTIALLY UNEMPLOYED.
ONE OF HER LAST REGULAR JOBS,
SHE WROTE BAD PORN NOVELS.
KAMALA HARRIS IS SO APPARENTLY
TRANSACTIONAL THAT EVEN
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY VOTERS FOUND
HER REPULSIVE.
PRETTY MUCH NO ONE WHO KNOWS
KAMALA HARRIS LIKES HER.
OVERALL, IT’S NOT A BLUE RIBBON
GROUP BUT ACCORDING TO
JOE BIDEN, THIS ISN’T A NORMAL
YEAR IN THE NORMAL STANDARDS
DON’T APPLY.
FOR WHAT COULD VERY WELL BE THE
MOST IMPORTANT JOB ON EARTH,
BIDEN HAS DECIDED TO HIRE
EXCLUSIVELY ON THE BASIS OF
QUALITIES THAT ARE BOTH
IMMUTABLE AND COMPLETELY
IRRELEVANT.
RACE AND GENDER.
THAT’S IT.
BUT WAIT A SECOND, YOU ASK,
ISN’T THAT INSULTING?
ISN’T IT WRONG?
ISN’T IT PROBABLY ILLEGAL?
YES, IT IS ALL THREE OF THOSE
THINGS BUT NO ONE IS PUSHING
BACK AGAINST IT SO BIDEN IS
DOING IT.
THE PROBLEM IS THAT ALL THREE OF
THE PEOPLE WE JUST TOLD YOU
ABOUT MIGHT WIND UP IN THE END
HURTING THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN.
THEY ARE JUST TOO UNIMPRESSIVE
TO RUN.
BIDEN’S HANDLERS SEEM TO HAVE
FIGURED THIS OUT.
ABOVE ALL, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
WANTS TO WIN THIS YEAR.
THEY ARE NOT IN IT FOR
SENTIMENTAL REASONS OR FOR LOVE
OF JOE BIDEN.
THEY ARE IN IT FOR THE POWER AND
THEY WANTED BADLY.
SO TODAY THE ODDS SEEMED TO
SHIFT DRAMATICALLY IN ANOTHER
DIRECTION, AWAY FROM KAREN BASS
AND KAMALA HARRIS AND STACEY
ABRAMS AND TOWARDS SOMEONE YOU
HAVE SEEN BEFORE.
IT WOULD BE FORMER NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR SUSAN RICE.
AS OF RIGHT NOW, SUSAN RICE
APPEARS TO BE IN THE LEAD FOR
THE VP SLOT.
THAT’S AN INTERESTING
DEVELOPMENT.
SAY WHAT YOU WILL ABOUT
SUSAN RICE, AND WE ARE ABOUT TO,
BUT SHE’S NOT A BUFFOON.
SUSAN RICE IS SMART.
SHE IS HARD I’D COME
EXPERIENCED.
SUSAN RICE KNOWS EXACTLY WHAT
SHE
WANTS AND SHE UNDERSTANDS THE
SYSTEM WELL ENOUGH TO GET IT.
SHE’S A THREAT.
WHAT EXACTLY DOES SHE BELIEVE?
SUSAN RICE BELIEVES WHAT
EVERYONE ELSE IN PERMANENT
WASHINGTON BELIEVES.
BECAUSE ABOVE ALL, RICE IS A
PRODUCT OF D.C.
SHE GREW UP THERE.
TO OUR POLITICAL CLASS, RICE IS
THE OPPOSITE OF AN OUTSIDER.
SHE IS THE HOME TEAM.
LIKE ALMOST EVERYONE IN
WASHINGTON, SHE IS ABOVE ALL A
FERVENT NEOCON.
AS A MEMBER OF OBAMA’S CABINET
SHE PUSHED THE COUNTERPRODUCTIVE
KILLING OF MUAMMAR QADDAFI IN
LIBYA.
SHE HAS NEVER APOLOGIZED.
FOR IT SHE SHOULD.
CLINTON ADMINISTRATION, SHE
SUPPORTED THE BOMBING OF A
PHARMACEUTICAL FACTORY.
IT GOES WITHOUT SAYING REALLY
RICE LED THE CHORUS OF LIARS WHO
CLAIMED DONALD TRUMP WAS
SECRETLY A RUSSIAN AGENT.
>> HE HAS TAKEN A SERIES OF
STEPS THAT HAVE VLADIMIR PUTIN
DICTATED THEM HE COULDN’T HAVE
MERITED MORE EFFECTIVELY.
WHAT HIS MOTIVATIONS ARE I THINK
OUR LEGITIMATE QUESTION, ONE
THAT I TRUST THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL IS INVESTIGATING.
THE POLICIES OF THIS PRESIDENT
HAVE SERVED VLADIMIR PUTIN’S
INTEREST IN DIVIDING THE WEST,
UNDERMINING DEMOCRACY.
>> DO YOU THINK IT’S AN OPEN
QUESTION WHETHER OR NOT HE’S
COMPROMISED BY RUSSIA?
>> I DON’T KNOW WHAT HIS
MOTIVATIONS ARE.
I THINK IT IS A LEGITIMATE
QUESTION.
>> Tucker: HA.
TO BE PERFECTLY CLEAR, THIS IS
NOT SOMEONE WHO’S JUST JUST
THROWING WORDS OUT.
THIS IS SOMEONE WHO IS HIGHLY
SOPHISTICATED THE NUANCES OF
FOREIGN POLICY.
IN OTHER WORDS, SUSAN RICE KNEW
PERFECTLY WELL WHEN SHE SAY WHAT
YOU JUST HEARD THAT IT WAS
FALSE.
SHE KNEW THAT MUCH OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION’S ACTUAL AGENDA
FROM ARMING UKRAINE TO EXPANDING
DOMESTIC ENERGY PRODUCTION HERE
IN THE U.S. HURTS RUSSIAN
INTERESTS BADLY.
AND YET RICE DIDN’T ACKNOWLEDGE
IT.
INSTEAD SHE SMEARED THE
PRESIDENT IS A KREMLIN POND.
WHAT RICE OBJECTED TO WORK
TRUMPS FOREIGN POLICY VIEWS.
VIEWS WHICH NOT INCIDENTALLY THE
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS SAY THEY
SUPPORT.
IT TURNS OUT THAT ONLY PEOPLE IN
WASHINGTON LIKE SUSAN RICE WANT
MORE POINTLESS WARS AROUND THE
WORLD BECAUSE THEY ARE THE ONES
WHO PROFIT FROM THEM.
MOST NORMAL PEOPLE DON’T WANT
MORE POINTLESS WARS BECAUSE
THEY’RE THE ONES WHO FIGHT THEM
BUT RICE DOESN’T CARE EITHER
WAY.
WATCH HER REACTION TO THE
ADMINISTRATION’S PLAN TO REMOVE
TROOPS FROM SYRIA.
>> I WOKE UP THIS MORNING TO
HEAR THAT NEWS AND AS I DO, IT
SEEMS LIKE SIX DAYS A WEEK I
JUST PUT MY HEAD IN MY HANDS.
THIS IS [BLEEP]
CRAZY.
>> Tucker: OH, YEAH.
IT’S CRAZY.
ALMOST UNBELIEVABLE.
IT’S CRAZY TO BRING TROOPS HOME
FROM A COUNTRY WE HAVE NO
STRATEGIC INTEREST IN.
FOR THERE TO FULFILL A MISSION
WE CAN’T
ARTICULATE.
THAT’S CRAZY.
BUT THAT’S THE CONSENSUS IN
WASHINGTON.
WHEN THE U.S. CONSULATE IN
BENGHAZI WAS DESTROYED IN 2012,
RICE HERSELF SAID SOMETHING THAT
WAS ACTUALLY CRAZY.
SHE BLAMED THAT ATTACK ON ON AN
ONLINE VIDEO.
ONCE AGAIN, RICE KNEW WHEN SHE
SAID IT IT WASN’T TRUE BUT SHE
SAID IT ANYWAY.
>> WHAT SPARKED THE RECENT
VIOLENCE WAS THE ERRING ON THE
INTERNET OF A VERY HATEFUL, VERY
OFFENSIVE VIDEO.
IT BEGAN SPONTANEOUSLY IN
BENGHAZI AS A REACTION TO WHAT
HAD TRANSPIRED HOURS EARLIER IN
CAIRO WHERE OF COURSE AS YOU
KNOW THERE WAS A VIOLENT PROTEST
OUTSIDE OF OUR EMBASSY SPARKED
BY THIS HATEFUL VIDEO.
WHAT HAPPENED IN BENGHAZI WAS IN
FACT INITIALLY A SPONTANEOUS
REACTION TO WHAT HAD JUST
TRANSPIRED HOURS BEFORE IN
CAIRO.
WHAT HAPPENED THIS WEEK IN
CAIRO, IN BENGHAZI, AND IN MANY
OTHER PARTS OF THE REGION.
>> TUNISIA, KHARTOUM.
>> A DIRECT RESULT OF A HEINOUS
AND OFFENSIVE VIDEO.
>> Tucker: IT WAS HEINOUS.
IT WAS OFFENSIVE.
IT WAS HATEFUL.
THIS VIDEO WHICH DARED CRITICIZE
RADICAL ISLAM.
PEOPLE SAW IT AND THEY WERE SO
OFFENDED THEY’D JUSTIFIABLY ROSE
UP AND STARTED SHOOTING
AMERICANS.
THAT WAS THE IMPLICATION OF WHAT
SHE SAID.
BUT RICE KNEW THAT WAS A LIE
WHEN SHE SAID IT.
SHE KNEW THE ATTACK IN BENGHAZI
WAS NOT SPONTANEOUS.
IT WASN’T BASED IN OUTRAGE, AND
IT WAS NOT STATED IN RESPONSE TO
THAT OR ANY OTHER VIDEO.
SHE KNEW THAT BECAUSE HER OWN
INTELLIGENCE REPORTS MADE IT
PERFECTLY CLEAR.
BUT IT WAS AN ELECTION YEAR.
AND RICE SAID WHAT SHE HAD TO
SAY.
BY THE WAY, THE MAN WHO ACTUALLY
MADE THE VIDEO, THE HEINOUS
OFFENSE OF HATEFUL VIDEO, WAS A
COPTIC CHRISTIAN.
HE WAS ARRESTED AFTER RICE’S
APPEARANCES ON TELEVISION.
HE WAS JAILED WITHOUT BAIL.
IT WAS A PURELY POLITICAL
PROSECUTION OF THE KIND THE REST
OF US REASSURE OURSELVES DOESN’T
HAPPEN IN THIS COUNTRY BUT
UNFORTUNATELY SOMETIMES DOES.
WHATEVER HAPPENED TO THAT MAN?
NO ONE CHECKED.
WE DID TODAY.
FOUR YEARS LATER HE WAS LIVING
IN A HOMELESS SHELTER.
HIS LIFE WAS COMPLETELY
DESTROYED.
SUSAN RICE HAS NEVER APOLOGIZED
TO HIM.
DOESN’T APPEAR DEEP EVEN LOOKED
BACK.
THAT IS A MORAL CRIME.
HAS RICE COMMITTED LEGAL CRIMES?
U.S. ATTORNEY JOHN DURHAM IS
LOOKING INTO IT AND WE WILL
BRING YOU THE RESULTS OF THAT
INVESTIGATION WHEN THEY FINALLY
APPEAR.
WE ARE STILL WAITING.
WE DO KNOW, THOUGH, THAT RICE
MONITORED CONVERSATIONS THAT
TRUMP ADVISORS WERE HAVING WITH
FOREIGN OFFICIALS AND THEN
REQUESTED THE UNMASKING OF THOSE
ADVISORS.
RICE WAS ASKED ABOUT THIS IN A
TELEVISION INTERVIEW AND HERE’S
HOW SHE RESPONDED.
>> DURING THE TRANSITION, AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD BEEN
ELECTED, HE AND THE PEOPLE
AROUND HIM MAY HAVE BEEN CAUGHT
UP IN SURVEILLANCE OF FOREIGN
INDIVIDUALS AND THEIR IDENTITIES
MAY HAVE BEEN DISCLOSED.
DO YOU KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT THIS?
>> I KNOW NOTHING ABOUT THIS.
I WAS SURPRISED TO SEE REPORTS
FROM CHAIRMAN NUNES ON THAT
COUNT TODAY.
>> Tucker: HERE IS JUST A PRO
TIP IN CASE YOU’RE WATCHING THIS
INTERVIEW AT HOME.
WHEN A POLITICAL FIGURE LAUGHS
IN A WAY THAT SUGGESTS NOT REAL
MIRTH BUT NERVOUSNESS IN THE
MIDDLE OF AN ANSWER, THAT’S A
TOWEL.
HE MEANS THEY’RE LYING.
AND IN FACT SHE WAS LYING.
WE KNOW THAT FOR CERTAIN.
THE OTHER THING WE KNOW IS
SUSAN RICE WITH SAY WHATEVER SHE
THINGS IT TAKES WAS NOT